du denkst arbeiten bei der post ist ein
job für totale looser für arme wurst die
sich den ganzen tag von irgendwelchen
kuttern ans bein besen lassen
von wegen
als bist du eine mischung aus magdeburg
und james ball
[Musik]
lasst die idioten ruhig glauben du
bringst ihnen pakete in wahrheit spion
ist du siehst du bist die stasi 2.0 für
cdu und fdp
findest du alles aus über jedes viertel
lasst doch die trottel von hermes pakete
bringen dafür bist du viel zu cool und
unser service für die nächste
bundestagswahl wählen direkt an der
haustür so und sie tippen jetzt auf
meinem scanner einfach auf die partei
die sie wählen nicht aber das steht ja
nur cdu
[Musik]
kommt zur post erich mielke wäre stolz
auf dich
[Musik]
der deutschen post